e
don't open up the subcommittee on
liquor
um we where the subcommittees has kind
of moved around and trying to sort it
all out so at this point uh uh pusc
Burrow's walls
Sullivan's here
okay all
right uh relative de Brew Pub
licenses
uh aren't I spons of this bill
uh yes sir you are well the sponsor list
is you no I just she just print
out somebody did call me and tell me
that this was all
wrong it had the wrong I love this had
the wrong it's the wrong
yeah
okay all right
cool yeah
original these are screwed up okay so we
have
walls
burrow
spear
okay so post is not
here
so oh this is wrong too okay oh there we
go okay so you're you're in sitting in
for
post
okay uh everybody understand this bill
this was the um from last year when the
along we were so excited that the that
the Senators said Cav that we uh didn't
pay attention to what we were
passing some of the other ones seem
straightforward okay uh is there anybody
here have a problem with us passing this
this uh this this bill speak now forever
more hold your peace seeing No Hands
okay um I'll I'll make the motion for a
second okay any discussion on the motion
about to
pass uh because everybody everybody
clear on who's on the subcommittee right
all those in favor raise your hand one
two three four five six everybody
here seven okay yeah that's the
okay do you guys how much you care about
this
neutral uh first of all for the record
uh Mr chairman uh Chief Mark armaganian
uh director of New Hampshire Liquor
enforcement licensing uh with me here
today is Deputy Chief Danielle ston
deputy director of the same entity um we
uh have been neutral on this uh piece of
legislation due to the fact that we see
both sides of the coin here um we
see um uh from the leny perspective the
possibility of uh Miniatures being in
the bathrooms loading up drinks at the
same time we see the negative effects of
leaving a drink on a table and and the
story that the representative shared
with us uh which is horrific so um so
with that being said uh I'll leave the
technical pieces uh to Danielle here but
uh from from the 10,000 foot level um
now okay any question anybody have
want to talk okay just stay right there
all right so uh this is your build
jar okay
um should be sure
kitchens uh areas
now because we did allow last we passed
another bill allows people to walk
around with their drinks anyways but
they're not being served they're being
served in so someone has to if they were
in the hallway if the place was I can't
say too crowded because there would be
fire fire regulations but uh they they
still have to come back to the bar to
get their drink correct and and walk
around um I guess the question I had was
here
was obviously the story you told was a
very old story okay and I don't know how
often this happens I I do remember the
days when it did happen you
then is oh by the way I did talk to a
recent restaurant owner and he was
talking about how the bathroom always
seems he's empty the bag always seems to
right in the garbage yeah and yeah uh I
have a family member who used to manage
a restaurant and so when I talked to her
if you remember the first was a 2023
when we had that bill to help um it was
we were passing that bill that would
punish over serving remember that bill
right um so I was speaking to her and
she said that like you know sometimes
they when they're emptying out the trash
whereever they'll see drinks in there
and so um yeah I I think that that
happens I think which I think kind of
further proves the point that if we
think that people people know that it's
illegal to drink
if you're under 21 and if people are
going to break that law or people know
that it's legal to bring alcohol into an
establishment and then their drinks
if you're going to break that law this
isn't like preventing it from happening
they're going to do it anyways right um
and so particularly if you're bringing
something from outside the
establishment my main concern and the
motivation for this obviously I share
the story but it's I think for the most
part people probably are taking I mean I
didn't even know basically I worked in
this role that this was illegal in New
Hampshire um I think most restaurants
owners don't know I've spoken to some
who were surprised to learn this so they
didn't even know who was the thing but
my point is is is what the motivation
the motivation behind this law or me
putting in this bill was when I actually
saw a sign at a restaurant saying you
can't do it because of alcohol some
restaurant and so if that's H and if if
that restaurant thinks it's in their
best business interest to continue to
prohibit it then they're welcome to do
that it doesn't require them to they can
go ahead and post that yeah they can
still post that sign but uh to the
extent that there are law abiding people
which obviously people who bring alcohol
into the restaurant are breaking the law
already but to the extent there are
people who will abide by laws and signs
and things like that leaving a drink
unattended exposes them to risk and
that's that's sort of my whole argument
so there are people who are already
breaking laws going into bathrooms and
drinking with alcohol that they didn't
purchase there or giving giving it to
minors whatever the concern may be those
people are going to do it regardless of
what this law is because this law is
already in the books and it's already
still happening but to the extent that
people who are law-abiding leave out
their drinks and and potentially expose
themselves to danger or harm is just it
just seems kind of pointless and um I
feel like this isn't going to suddenly
lead to a wave of people like oh sweet
now that I can bring alcohol into the
into the bathroom I can start spiking
all my drinks where I couldn't before I
mean if they wanted to do that they're
do that now so I I just don't see that
this is going to open up a door to a
bunch of illegal activity that currently
people where people are currently
abiding by the law that's my thinking on
it um so in terms of enforcement how
often have you you guys have enforcement
issues around U people taking their
currently on the current law taking
drinks into the bathroom I mean we do we
do have we we do encounter situations
where we find drinks in the restroom
um the way that we have um applied the
enforcement to this in the past is that
the lensey has mitigating factors in
place they have signage the staff is
regularly checking the restroom the
restroom is clean the restroom safe um
we understand that you know even if you
leave a a drink out as the
representative said there's there's
stuff to come in so this isn't something
we heavily enforce um right now again we
we want to see it we want it clean we
want it safe we want it monitored you
know anytime you can post signage or or
inform the the public of what the the
rules are that's to the benefit of the
ly
okay uh I'll let Chris because he says I
never recognize him yes representative
Herbert I'm gonna bring a flag so you
emergency um I have a my observation is
unless I'm I'm misunderstanding the this
uh
Bill uh I'm I'm 75 years old and I've
been a drinker for a long time and I
have I have never seen
anybody take booze into the restroom uh
I've never seen it I mean maybe it
happens but um I know I've never done it
and I don't see any reason why you would
do that but uh it's to me it's I mean I
I will take a beer with me into the
bathroom if I'm walking in there I mean
I don't
know it's so because you haven't seen it
doesn't mean other people maybe don't
want to do that you know are you are you
for or against this bill I'm against it
okay because you don't see there's any
need and that it's perfectly fine to
make it keep it illegal is that
correct you you don't even see reason to
change the law that makes it illegal to
take your drink into into the restroom
no I I don't I think it's a non-event
anyway but uh well it may it may be
happening but uh I'm not I'm not aware
of it and do you do you understand do
you understand that it's not necessarily
that I'm trying to encourage people to
take their drinks into the bathroom like
that's not my goal of this bill all I'm
saying is if somebody thinks it's in
their best interest to take a drink into
the bathroom because they have no
friends or they're waiting for somebody
at a bar and if they leave it there it
exposes it to potentially being spiked
that is is my concern and so that's the
motivation of the bill I'm not trying to
say hey everybody bring your drinks into
the bathroom that's the fun place to
drink in the bar like that's that's
insane I'm not doing that
Barz okay I'm I'm a sponsor of this bill
and I support it I just want to make two
points one is you know we you were
saying that you haven't had had any
recent examples there's one that big in
the news it's not in New Hampshire um
You probably read about these three
Realtors who were you know top realtors
were drugging women um spiking their
drinks one of them was on um million
doll listing the the the um the realtor
and she was found in a bathroom being
assaulted and another realtor pulled
them off and they are probably going to
go to jail for life but you know if
there is push back on this bill I mean I
thought of another possible solution
which would be do voluntarily for for
bars to have a place behind the bar
where women can leave or anybody could
leave their drinks and maybe you know a
tag to put their name on
it a safe zone right we we do have
several establishments who have um put
in practices for um for for variety of
different things um they sell covers to
your drinks that you can put on your
drinks there's um there's apps that you
can actually use now where you can show
the bartender and say you know can you
make me this drink and it means certain
things that I need help or can you get
me out of the situation so we do see
that throughout the state where there's
options or they put in safe practices um
to make the customers feel more
comfortable and again in terms of the
lensey they can take any law on the
street and restrict it to within their
business practices to whatever they feel
they need to do to have a successful run
business so the lenses would still be
able to prohibit drinks in the restroom
if they chose to do that and and that's
just a business practice that they can
enact okay uh
Henry I don't see Mike here are you
I guess the question would be is this is
one of those classic uh with the
restaurants want us to keep it simply
because they don't want to be the
responsible to put up the sign that says
don't bring your drink into the bathroom
or you just don't really care one way or
the other and just assume not have the
Liquor Commission worrying about yeah so
Mike testified at the hearing on this
bill Mike Henry veu lodging Restaurant
Association and um we had a government
Affairs meeting with um 25 of The
Operators uh so we got a good
perspective and feel of how the industry
uh you know thinks about this bill um
they fully understand uh the motivation
for it um they came down with a feeling
that it would make it much more
difficult in uh managing because they're
responsible for the drinking within
their establishment and it just would
make it much more difficult uh with this
uh added um a number of them said uh
that more and more establishments are um
uh having cameras in uh their facilities
uh again it's it it would help to
convict someone um afterwards uh it
doesn't do anything to prevent the
instance uh that you were describing but
it would at least have um you know the
video of the individual uh doing uh the
practice and maybe uh that would deter
folks uh but uh generally uh the folks
um in the industry think that this would
uh make it a little more complicated for
them in
policing in policing in policing in
managing the people their drinks in the
over over service and underrage drinking
I mean those are the two things they
have to be concerned about and um so
they would just prefer to leave the law
as it is
yeah right I mean I remember he was it
was clear one way or the other sound
like he wasn't really taking a position
but it was
just okay representative
S I mean I know that you represent you
represent the industry but you don't
represent everybody because I've spoken
to several and if I had known this was
going to be controversial I would have
lined them up to come for this but uh
who who just think it's it's a silly law
in fact they didn't even know it existed
so I guess my counter is if they don't
want people drinking in in in their
restaurant bathrooms they just put up a
sign saying no alcohol in the bathroom I
mean if that's really what they need to
the extent that somebody is going to
break the current law with a sign up
there or not they're going to break any
sign that you put up whether this law is
in existence or not so if they they
don't want people drinking in the
bathrooms why why wouldn't if they think
it makes it easier to say hey no alcohol
permitted in the bathroom and
then basically nothing has changed for
them they can still go in hey you're
breaking our policy you know we I don't
think we should be making
legislation limiting all restaurants
because a few want a certain policy they
want that policy they can enact it um I
think many restaurants in
this state don't care or think it's
something that they they don't want to
worry about or or whatever they don't
even know it exists um so the extent
that there are people who want that then
they just put up a sign I don't
understand how that doesn't accomplish
the same
thing that sounds like a would you
believe I would believe would you
believe I
believe representative
perz yeah I I have a question um little
little off the bill but is there a way
to educate
your clients and people who have bars
about the dangers to women or it's
usually women I mean it could happen to
a man having their drink Spike so that
you know there you know we could look at
some solution if if this bill doesn't
pass such as having a safe Zone because
it does happen it happens a lot with
college kids I I think it happens a lot
more than than you know bar owners may
may know
yep the the industry is aware of it um
and to your point I think wants to try
spear in reading the wording
here how do you get out of it that a a a
a an establishment can still put up a
sign saying
no no uh you can't drink in the bathroom
because it doesn't say that it says that
the patrons May take it in take the take
the alcohol in the wording is not Bing
what you want so as as Danielle said any
law we have can be further restricted by
The Establishment so if if they want to
put up a law they can we're not saying
you must allow it just allows the bill
allows patrons on premise to
establishments to take a purchased
beverage into the restroom it doesn't
say You must require them if it said
must I would I would agree but uh as
Danielle said what she was saying
any law or regulation we have can be
further restricted by any
establishment The Establishment can do
it he they don't need enabling
legislation to allow them to have the
further rules and the same thing like
right now I do we legalize you can bring
it on the Dance Floor last was that last
term or on the stage that that was the
performers but the performers right but
if presumably if the restaurant doesn't
want performers consuming alcohol they
could they could that I hate the nitpick
because I've written specs all my life M
this wording directs the patron not the
establishment the rule is on the patron
it's not on the establishment so it's
not clear I think the wording needs to
change just a little bit but
am
maybe I you everything that we do here
is on YouTube
okay okay I would say that the the way
the statue is written okay this is uh
terms of rest you know permissible okay
um was that originally you know they
saying was banned so no beverage can be
taken in consumed in foyers hallways or
kitchens that's still in the Statue all
right so all this sat this is doing is
giving guidance about where they
can't you where they can't do it it does
not go on to tell the establishment how
they want to create their own rules of
what they can or can't do in their
facility okay um but that is did and
just says that patrons may take a
beverage when I see the may may implies
that there are some establish that
establishments would be have the right
to say no they can't take it now whether
you want to add another sentence to it
to say however the the the uh the lense
he may uh May ban it if if they want to
you don't really need to do that because
the way because the word may is there
and exactly because the way the word may
is there it's confusing as to who is
being directed to do what yeah if if we
don't typically do that that's fine it's
just not it's speckmans ship that's all
okay
great uh uh is there anybody else who
thank you Henry anybody else have any
strong opinions one way or the other
about this
bill all right uh representative
Sullivan second by representative
discussions any
discussions you want to wave your flag
over
there I don't think there's any need for
legisl in this in this of any type I
think the restaurant owners have the
ability to U you know create their own
environment and I don't think anybody's
going to sit there and say you can go
ahead and have a beer and no the
restaurant they can't though right now
they can't they can allow allow that so
what does this I don't understand why
this is here because right now it is
illegal to take if you're if you're at
the bar and you buy a beer and then you
have to go use the restroom you you
cannnot take it in there it's illegal
illegal to take it in there so this will
simply enable to do exactly what you
just said which is to allow the
restaurant to create the environment
they want if they don't want people
taking them in there they can put up a
sign if if they don't care then then
then this will allow a patron to bring
it with
them so so the concern is the is the
concern is as I said in the in the I
don't know maybe you weren't here uh
last week but I have a I have a friend
who was at a
restaurant and or at a bar and had one
drink and then woke up in a hotel room
that wasn't theirs and had clearly been
raped and so somebody had spiked their
drink with ruies or whatever drugs that
they use to spike the drink and so my
argument is that it's best to be in
control of your drink at all times and
that's when I was in college there was a
whole education campaign because there
was a problem that some of the
fraternity where where people's drinks
were being spiked and so they had a
whole campaign of always being control
of your your your drink and so the law
currently prevents people from being
able to be in control of their drink if
they need to use the restroom and they
have a drink they have no place to put
it maybe they're alone at the bar maybe
they're whatever there any number of
reasons why if they choose to bring it
in them in with them into the restroom
that would provide an element of safety
because they're in control of their
drink at that time and that's the
purpose of right now that they would not
be allowed to do that so that's the goal
of this
bill does that make sense I'm not saying
you have to take the drinks into the
bathroom well you know this is
hypothetical things that that might
happen I mean if if you get a spike
drink I don't think you being in the
bathroom is going to be a problem no
that's not I think you missed it is if
if I leave my drink on the bar and run
to the restroom right then a person who
wants to spike my drink has an
opportunity because there's nobody
monitoring that drink if I have that
drink in my possession in the bathroom
then it would be much more challenging
yes it's always a way you could probably
get it in if I'm you know talking to
representative post and I'm having a
drink and here somebody could do
something but it's a lot less likely
that that would happen in that
circumstance if it's just sitting on the
table it's different so I I uh
parliamentary that was uh I should not
have allowed him to speak because he's
not on the subcommittee so not
withstanding I did I did want him to at
least have one more chance to make his
case Okay is the motion clear uh the the
motion is ought to pass all those in
favor raise their hand one two three
four
five and who's
opposed six seven okay so that's so that
edit I'm I'm perfectly willing to let it
go but okay my ranking member says I
should say something okay
blame I want to to pass the the sentence
should say if the restaurant if the
establishment allows house it's up to
the establishment patrons may take
beverages that have been purchased from
The Establishment into the restroom over
that establishment if the restaurant
allows otherwise this is open to ambigu
ambiguity ly right it should say ly yeah
that's
allows patrons Bay
take I think that's what
yeah but I don't know I'm just trying to
think if that if that kind of is
counterproductive because because
basically you're saying that that it's
still illegal unless they
they unless unless you're basically
saying it remains illegal unless the
restaurant comes out with a policy
saying that you can have it in there and
all I'm saying is it's legal unless the
opposite unless they don't want it in
there then put those words in there like
that because right now it says let's go
fight it
out okay we do have the we do have the
enforcer here
enforcer Deputy Deputy enforcer Deputy
enforcer um so if I could maybe help
with this um for this legislation
particularly if you want to allow drinks
in the restroom you can simply just
strike the word restroom from The
Establishment there's other laws that
create required areas of service
approved areas of service but you
wouldn't even need the language that
said now patrons are allowed to bring it
in if you just strike the word restroom
oh that's much better then you don't
even need an extra
line and then like other words in other
words that whole bold face don't need it
you don't even need it you can just
write the word restroom all we're doing
is drinks in the restro all we're doing
is just deleting the word restrooms then
that way we don't fight over that
way in other words it just says they
they can't they can't uh no B Li shall
be served or
consumed so
theoretically um this does allow them to
drink their drink in the bathroom
because it doesn't we are deleting the
word bathroom restroom
correct a little bit
simpler I like
simple all right I'll reach out to OS
and just have them fix that well we can
I'll take care of that you'll do it okay
I'll take care of that okay so we're
basically uh let's re re
thanks Daniel uh motion motion to
reconsider representa hunt moves to
reconsider our action sub commmittee all
those in favor reconsidering please say
I all right that's unanimous um now the
question now will be that
representative uh make sure I have the
right piece of paper in front of
me okay uh representative s second by
representative buroughs moves the
amendment uh which we don't have yet so
theoretically we will right now okay
um
discussion for and an
amendment
that
face
sentence okay thank you very much okay
so that we will will take that up at
okay a hotel to your we've already did
we already passed that okay we already
passed that
yeah that's already been
done okay
uh
okay all right uh
so
yesterday uh my meeting in Pittsburgh
ended at 2 o'clock but my flight didn't
leave till 6
o'clock and so therefore I had lots of
time on my hands
and got really informed about this issue
mention
okay no that would
be next
extension okay so what what we turned
out is that um we've heard in the public
uh testimony was that um this sort of
this problem really got created with the
Department of Safety
uh had a statute in which they generated
rules um which um I think most of us
would probably read those rules and say
boy they need to revisit these
rules and but we don't really have that
purview so I will I'm trust from the
Department that they will they will re
revisit their rules anyways um I've
heard that they have a whole new more
creative system that they hope to
implement um that will not only be the
green red green but also be able to
identify whether the the license or the
document that's being handed is is a
forgery it's a fake uh but that they
assure me that whatever storage system
or any that being transmitted back to uh
the department of safety who would have
the the main computer who reference it
that they um they would only last it
would only last for about 30 seconds and
then that whole question of that request
would disappear and so that um no one
have to be fear fear that that that
their information is being stored at the
department of safety um not withstanding
that um getting back now to the uh
underlying issue that we have which was
that in terms of the um and I had a very
interesting conversation with the
consumer protection because my original
idea was to stick it in the consumer
protection act as a uh
um is a violation um and um I was
convinced by Brandon that to not do that
because it doesn't solve anything and he
says in his mind and evidently consumer
protection gets a lot of phone calls of
complaints about that the businesses are
storing personal identification
information and he is very grateful that
we are some we're trying to address this
issue um but that the same time he um he
dides not want to have or anybody think
that they have that they could just
randomly go into certain businesses and
try to audit their business and see if
they really are
storing information whether they are or
not the accusation is there and the uh
Department of safety's statute has the
implementation that they could be
storing names and driver's license okay
so what we're have here is something
that uh we do one people a group of
people we do know uh who have the power
to investigate and have the the power to
look into somebody's computer is that's
the uh Liquor Commission because we want
to make sure that they are reporting
their sales correctly and I'm reporting
uh you know terms of of um that so they
can look at their computer and they can
see if somebody was really intentionally
storing the data even though we've been
told you know from multiple PES that
that that is not the intent uh that no
one wanted to store your information
however there was some uh awareness that
um it when it came to um pawn shops that
pawn shops do are actually required to
carry some information so we're this is
uh we're assuming this is not a pawn
chop issue okay we're taking this is
this is a uh issue of New Hampshire
convenience stores
we we call off- premises lenses that
that it's their issue and that we want
to make it clear that they cannot be
storing any that data and that is what
the paragraph
says assuming everybody's had a chance
to read it anybody have any reactions uh
negative or posit this is not an
official Amendment so we would have to
have another subcommittee to to vote on
this but uh this is your chance now for
anybody to tell us this is a bad way to
do it so yes if you would like to come
and I'm not exactly sure you have to
turn the mic on yep push the button
perfect I'm not exactly sure when we
have
laws how they get enforced um and and
and I'll give you a short story about I
I found out in 2013
that there was a law that said that um
you couldn't charge more to an uninsured
Health insured
person than you could to an insured
Health um Health person yet when I went
to the State Insurance website there
were two buttons are you insured or are
you not insured so you could check and
see how much a typical procedure would
cost in either in any hospital and I
proved to the attorney general that this
was illegal that that the law said that
you can't charge more because it was
like three times more for somebody
uninsured and his response to me back
then was well nothing was put in the law
that said who's going to enforce it so
there's nothing I can do okay so I can
actually tell you that one because I
wrote that law and so I know exactly
what you're talking about and you did
call the wrong people uh the uh consumer
protection act the AG is exempt from the
consumer protection act when it comes to
insurance that that issue would should
have been dealt with with the insurance
department you should have called the
insurance department and they would have
walked you through how that law was
being enforced well I actually did it
was the insurance department's website
it was the state I understand that but
you needed to talk to a real human being
I actually did talk to them and got
nowhere and so went to the attorney
general so there was no way I could I me
as a as a consumer needs to know what
what happens when something finds out so
I'm looking at this and I'm saying well
first of all I think that there should
be a huge penalty to any any entity
that's the penalty is very huge they can
lose their license to operate they
should it should be more than that when
you're when you're talking about
people's identity but who's going to
enforce it the Liquor Commission so does
it are you adding that to this bill so
that people know when they look at a
bill this bill if you uh it seems like
you're pretty astute and using your
computer um I would urge you to look up
U Section 179
and you will see 179 is enforced by The
Liquor Commission and and they're very
serious people they they actually carry
guns you know they're they're so they
they will absolutely if they find that
some Merchant is storing that data they
will threaten his license say that on
the law so if I look up that law I'm
going to see this is the the party I go
to because it didn't say it it didn't
say it on the law that I looked up and
went to the State Library and did a
whole bunch of research on and I never
found any any other place where it said
in that law who I should go to okay so
um we uh when you're finished I will
have the Liquor Commission come up tell
you what exactly RSA that they could
yank that person's license if they
violated stat could or will or or what
if the if they don't do it then where do
I go they I can assure you that if they
see a violation if they see someone
storing this
information they will abs absolutely
threaten that they will require him they
will have a hearing and they will bring
that that leny in it would be just as
bad as if they if the lensey sold to
someone who was under 21 or someone that
the lensey served someone who was over
served who was drunk what if it's
Macy's who Macy's Macy's as in the
department store scanning licenses to uh
to verify somebody that they're that
they are the person on the credit card
name so we we are this subject what
we're doing is trying to we we we
working on the concept is how do we make
it enforcable how do we which is really
what your question was so in terms of
Macy's if Macy's has a system to to ask
you to scan your card I can tell you
that um you can call the Attorney
General on this one because he did tell
me a story in which uh he got a
complaint that someone uh went into it
was a um
uh rental I guess it was it campers it
was a camper store like campers world or
something okay and they went in there
and before they let the customer walk
around the store they wanted to scan
their
license and uh and he absolutely called
up that establishment and that
establishment stop doing that okay and
that was the Attorney General's office
because camper that kind of retail
transaction he does regulate so in this
case we're saying is if a liquor
establishment any liquor license
C which is either a restaurant or a
convenience
store beer distributor for that matter
but Scott left the room I I I get what
you're saying and I see by the by by
the the ACT here prohibiting businesses
from scanning licenses when selling
alcohol or tobacco products now I am
kind of I think the Catalyst that
started this whole whole issue on on on
this because I was writing articles on
seeing this the driver's licensees
scanned uh but it's not you know it's
not limited to just um alcohol and
tobacco it's other people that are
scanning and even at uh I guess I think
it was the dairy or the wind
um election polls they were scanning the
driver's licenses there I guess they
were asking the election no polls that's
said there's a state statute that
requires them to to scan to look at your
license look at your license but not
scan to check to sure not use a scanning
SCH this this is pole pad using a
scanning system you would I guess there
would have to be separate legislation
that would go the election law committee
to say this need to go further that yes
but I hope you see this as a good start
step forward but I think that has
enforceability um I want you to hear
that I it I don't think I don't see
where um okay I I will now have the
Liquor Commission come up and tell you
exactly what statute they have to
enforce this so for the Macy's that's
going to have to wait for another bill
uh between you and me if some Merchant
some
business ask me for my license and I
haven't done any business with him
I haven't done anything and they had
they say I want I want to scan your
license to see whether you're 21 or not
or scanning for whatever reason I would
say thank you very much and leave the
establishment that's that's what I would
say too but unfortunately it's that's
not the world we live in now and we've
taught people that it's okay to to to
give out this identity especially
younger people they don't understand the
world that we should be living in and
what we're living in is 1984 but I'm not
going to carry this out any longer are
we saying that you there there are
businesses that without doing any
transactions you not handing in a card
or anything like that just to walk in
the door or asking to scan your license
so that's that that's what he explained
I my guess
is my guess is it's a it's it's a slow
place they don't have a lot going on and
they were skinny because they they
actually probably did make a copy of it
and they were putting you on their
mailing list
or they didn't like the looks of you or
they were profiling you yeah
yeah it's a big issue it's a big issue
and it needs it needs
further um
Attention our privacy information needs
this is a power this is a consumer
beware mean I think yet yes you're doing
a great job in in informing consumers
that they should not be whipping out
their driver's license for anybody who
asked for it they should really be more
conscious of don't don't give it to
anybody don't only give it well the
thing is is our our our it
our it shouldn't be possible what we are
we are our our our ability to move
freely which is a constitutional right
is limited by the fact that the state
says you have to give us this
information and we're going to retain it
and we're going to give you a card with
that information on it that's a driver's
license that that information should be
only for driving it shouldn't be for
everything else on earth like our social
security is now that that isn't that
isn't really quite true we use it for
identification for a number of different
things we do use it that way but
originally when when we were told I I
mean you don't look like you know like
if you go back years and years this you
talked about slippery slopes this is the
slippery slope is it is used for a lot
of stuff now just like our social
security number is that was supposed to
be for for for employment information
only now if I want to pay my electric
bill I got to give the last four digits
of my social security number give me a
rest you know I mean now it's used the
social security number is used for
everything it's give me your papers
please every place you go we are living
in 1984 and we and when we turn when we
first had driver's licenses it was only
supposed to be for driving but it's the
slippery slope it's become for
everything else Under the Sun just like
the Social Security number and now we
are in a situation where elderly people
are being ripped off their homes are
being stolen for criminy
sakes um so where is the slippery slope
going to
end and that's that's a problem that we
need to you know at least in the in the
liyy of die State we need to look at
this as a whole and say we've got to
stop
this fair enough thank you does anybody
want to ask me
anything I think we're all set okay
thank you
to
hello um so this is an amendment just to
a current statute within title 13 uh RSA
17956 through RSA 17959
covers our prosecution Authority our
enforcement of everything within the
title um one thing that we would have to
do if this law were to pass is we would
have to um amend a rule to establish a
penalty for this particular law if um we
want a specific penalty for the law
that's where we would put it in here um
if that's what the committee chooses a a
flat fine or or suspension for the law
then it would go in the statute but as
of right now all penalties fin
suspensions points uh an administrative
rule again those statutes gives us the
authority to create the rule to create
the penalties in Rule and then enforce
it accordingly from there um also one
thing to mention too um if this law were
to pass we do have a very we do have
very good communication with our leny
we're constantly sending out industry
circulars to the lenses where we could
update them about this law inform them
of the changes the penalties um and what
they need to do to stay in
compliance any questions comme
members thank you very
much okay so uh this is assuming that
everybody's kosher with this that um
we're we'll take this up uh once we have
the amendment drawn
up are you is y you could certainly yes
um thank you for letting me ask a
question so technology is changing very
rapidly I understand the concept of
storage but do you think that to really
draw the full circle we need to say
something about transmitting you know it
doesn't mean you have to store it you
could real time transmit it somewhere
well you got to you got to store it
before you can transmit it I don't know
about that yeah you got you got you got
you can't you just like you can't send F
file's got to exist before you can do
something with it yeah but um ass that
the storage means you cannot transmit it
to your you know marketing partner right
so was describing about what's going on
maybe John you want to come up and just
talk about what you guys are working in
the department of safety because the the
issue is not just 21 and everything like
that the issue is a greater issue which
is that a lot of people are getting uh
false IDs and how we're going to sniff
that out and so this is for motor
vehicles and uh the director and thank
you for coming Mr chairman thank you so
much members of the committee thank you
for allowing me to speak this morning uh
representative thank you for the uh the
phone call call last night and the
opportunity to talk about some of the
things that we're doing at the DMV to
make this process more seamless uh make
sure it complies with Rule and law and
um make sure that businesses know what
they can and can't do and also that
consumers like the um um the resident
that we just heard from uh concerns that
are out there actually the concerns that
were highlighted here just a few moments
ago I do hear about on a regular basis
um both from businesses what can I do
what can't I do and from residents that
say well I've had my license scanned I
didn't want that uh where is my personal
information is it on a server somewhere
how do I get it back and who is going to
enforce it who's going to follow up and
investigate this so um I've been in this
position for just under three years um
it's come to my attention from the
minute I landed there at the driver
Privacy Act
2614 um so one of the things that we've
done is there is a state statute that
was passed in 2019 that allows for dld
DV the driver LIC data verification
program
it's run through anva the American
Association of Motor Vehicle
administrators um anva is the best
practice Organization for DMVs uh
throughout North America they run the
program so basically what this means to
the representative to the chair's point
it's a red light green light system and
we had to uh do it in two parts we've
been working on it over the last year
and a half first part was syncing with
Social Security uh which we were one of
two states in the country that wasn't on
this program uh New Hampshire and Alaska
uh now we are on the program uh Social
Security somebody loses a social
security card because we have the
program they can more quickly get a
replacement card because the DMV
database has their information they've
already shown one in the past the second
part of it that's exciting and that
really applies to this conversation is
um about two months ago maybe a little
bit more we signed off on the retail
aspect of it so what does that mean uh
for context of what we're talking about
this morning means a convenience store
um any uh place that sells alcohol or
tobacco um could sign on with anva they
actually are the ones that do the
onboarding so you go directly to the
trusted organization which we already
use at the DMV and DMVs around the
country use their platform they already
have a pipeline into our system they're
a trusted Source you on board with Amber
uh you have an agreement with Amber you
have the scanning equipment that you
need uh John comes into the store to buy
whatever you're selling I give you my
license they scan my license it goes to
anva it goes to the DMV it comes back to
amva and they get a response back and I
ask for the screen of what it actually
looks like if I'm the business uh the
response comes back is true it's all you
need to know true it's not a fake ID uh
that information is real true the red
light green light at that point it
disappears uh off the anvas system
within 30 seconds or less and now the
business knows uh whether it's a test
drive for a car here you go you can take
the fob and and go out with the $80,000
car I know who you are I see the photo
that's you and I got the true response
for the information on on the front of
the license so your retail stores can
use it your automobile dealers uh can
use it um the hospital Association can
use it to check in patients um and
establishments that sell liquor and
tobacco can use it I want to thank uh
director armaganian uh we've already had
conversations about this uh he's very
interested we actually have reached out
to Philip quinland who is the point of
contact for the program for amva and uh
as of yesterday we're we're going to
finalize a date um to uh to get together
myself director armaganian and Phil
quinland from anva and talk about the
possibility so I really think DV is
going to solve this issue and you won't
have the storage uh you will have the
scanning but the 2019 statute allows for
it um but it's only for the true false
response on the license so uh that's
where we're heading and I think it's
going to clear up a lot of what the the
chair said um I got to tell you the the
rule set relating to driver privacy um
you know corresponding to the statute
believe uh from 2003 and
2004 or or two and three um it's uh it's
a lot and um to try to understand it and
relate it back to uh RSA 2614 and RSA
26312 um it needs to be simplified so
sir we're going to work on that thank
good to hear yeah okay is that you feel
more
comfortable good just yeah re I didn't
spell that I I couldn't quite CCH oh
yeah the the acronym yeah yeah I know uh
dld DV data licens uh data
verification dlvd and you uh dld
DV David Lincoln David
Victor driver licens data verification a
lot of acronyms at the DMV Sor what's
amva uh am Ena is the American
Association of Motor Vehicle
administrators so uh DMV directors um
throughout North America I'm honored to
be on the board of directors for anva
for over a year National Organization it
represents DMVs all the different DMVs
yeah Best Practices um States and
District of Columbia yes yeah technology
customer they must have even like Puerto
Rico and all yeah I don't know about
Guam they they have been going to Europe
quite a but I know they're trying to
bring on um some countries over in
Europe to the uh Association
so okay thank you very much thank you
sir all right so we will uh take that up
at another time next up is question
before you go on are we going to be
evaluating your Amendment or something
else I'm going to be sending this
amendment to legislative services oh
okay so this this is what we're looking
at this is it should look like this okay
I have a quick question chair yes um so
Danielle said that we would have to put
a either it's going to be in rule for
put the penalty he already they already
have rule making Authority so we're just
going to leave it that way yeah they you
know they'll go ahead and as you might
remember we had a previous discussion
about uh
penalties and we decid that there was
one penalty that we did want to put in
the statute and that was for someone who
died but that otherwise um the
department does the penalties through Ru
making all their general rule rules
I'm looking over them to see them say
yes
John but they're in deep in thought yes
that's the way that's the way it's done
so we don't need to give them rule
making Authority they already have it so
okay um I just uh emailed or texted uh
Peter Lehman uh because he was here but
he's not here
anymore um to study the privatization of
the Liquor
is there anyone here who thinks this is
idea think it's a yeah private
privatizing right anybody want to speak
for I I I'm not I wouldn't say I'm Pro
or against I right I mean I guess if if
if we go down that direction I think we
need to have a good faith we don't want
to Stack with a bunch of people who want
it privatized or stack it with a bunch
of people who are Love The Liquor
Commission I think
my experience so far on committees uh or
study commissions hasn't commissions
rather hasn't been great and I just feel
like um it's really easy to say you're
doing something and not have anything
actually like
the I was on a commission with you yes
that was predetermined before Mia just
like I was and uh and so I yeah I I
think if you're GNA do it then like
actually do a deep dive I mean I think
there's some interesting questions to go
in here it doesn't mean you know people
in this room probably think I want to
privatize I wouldn't even say that I am
curious what the benefits could be and
if we have a study commission that would
actually look at what are the benefits
of the current system versus what are
the benefits if we were not have it and
to have some sort of objective way to
achieve that that would be an
interesting thing um I'm just concerned
that you would have people who aren't
there in good faith but are coming in
with a
pre the problem is the commission can be
stacked with people and and so I just I
don't have a ton of
after my my experience on a commission
and commissions so talk about a
commission yeah this afternoon also so
um yeah I know there's another one
coming but anyways I think it's an
interesting question and I would I would
love to actually see it studied in a
good faith way um I am I'm a little
skeptical about how the problem is
getting it if you're really going to do
an empirical discussion you know you
would say is okay you have to go look
and see where it's been done mhm and it
the only case that's even close to doing
it was Maine and and they it was the end
result was what you those of us who were
opposed to the idea of privatization was
that it it meant a radical reduction in
state revenue you're basically sharing
whatever the state was making you're
sharing that Revenue now with private
businesses so uh as a republican you and
Li and somewhat accused of being a
Libertarian every once in a while that
that you would think that's great yeah
government shouldn't be in this business
you know government should not be in
anything that you're going to say it's a
sin and you like regulating sins what's
that you're going to say the sin things
are what the government should bu but I
that is true I have said that to you
before that I that that the one thing
that state you government could should
do is sin but um I mean I I generally
also am accused of being a Libertarian
despite the D next to my name um
but I know I mean I think I think it'd
be interesting I think it would be
interesting study to do if we could do
it effectively you to have an outside
entity doing it you would have to be
can't be anybody on that commission
should have their fingers on that study
that study needs to be truly independent
yeah independent and you're going to
spend lots of money and and but at the
end of the day the the same results
going to come back is yes you're you're
you're you're shooting based on that
comment you shouldn't be on the
commission why I would you should not be
on that commission I should not be
because you're going to kill the Golden
Goose I mean that's that's the whole
point yeah representative
spear the the obligation of a business
is to make money for the owners or the
stockholders of that business there is
no essential obligation to make any
money for the state and and that's the
overarching thing and so therefore the
whole concept seems to be against what
we set the Lial Commission of four in
the first place so I which was what
which was to make money for the state y
uh see I would differ I would say that
because they have multiple tasks the
other task is enforcing uh alcohol
consumption in the state to making sure
that it is done that is important it is
done uh safely yes and I believe that
our forefathers you know not that I was
in the room back in
1934 when they passed this legislation I
thought you were that uh that they they
that part of the reason they choose to
be a controlled state is they thought
the state would be uh better apt at
controlling um who who was able to I I
have no disagreement with that I think
those are the two-prong things that we
would lose if we win private and as as
as revenues go down sorry sorry as
revenues go down I have seen in other
states where the sale of alcohol ends up
being in in less than lovely places and
that people are getting shot youing
holding up liquor stores we we're in a
we have we have a very good
implementation and and I would hate to
see that ruin yes okay uh represent did
you want to respond to her yeah no I was
just saying I think I think again I
actually don't have an opinion whether
we should or not I am just curious but I
think if the idea is making money for
the state then there is an there is an
opportunity cost that we're giving up
and it's whether whether or not that
would be greater so for example let's
say the number thrown out there was we
could sell it or privatize it and
somehow gain a billion dollars put that
billion dollars into a fund that kicks
off I don't know $50 million a year or
something forever um that that might be
I'm not I'm not saying that it would be
you're looking at me as if I've come to
a predetermined conclus I'm just saying
there are opport my point is there are
opportunities that haven't been explored
and that's all I'm saying you know when
you talk about killing the Golden Goose
well the Golden Goose might be hey like
maybe the liquor industry is collapsing
and and in 20 years we're look back at
and say wow we don't get anything from
alcohol anymore because nobody consumes
it anymore and we could have cashed out
got a billion dollars back in
2025 and put it into a into some sort of
state fund that just kicks off interest
every year I mean all I'm saying those
are the types of things a commission
should study to understand what they are
without actually coming in with a a
conclusion that status quo is the best
maybe it is the best and hopefully it
would come up with whether it is or
isn't is all I'm saying just in in
coming up with that whoever threw out
that billion dollar number I'm not
saying it's good or bad I'm just saying
look at the size of our state let's be
realistic is somebody going to buy you
know I mean if you're going to it just
doesn't I okay maybe the billion dollars
is not I'm just saying for it it might
very well be unreasonable that could be
figured out like I could probably figure
out a rough estimate of what would be if
I just went through their books right
like that's kind of an accounting
process that could be done um they have
great real estate there's probably some
value in that I know they don't own all
of it but they own some of it like
there's a lot of different assets there
that a a thorough study which probably
wouldn't be done I think John's probably
right it would have to be an outside
study not a it would cost hundreds of
thousands of doll cost maybe you should
hire me to do it I'm an economist I do
these
sorts um you have a conflict yeah very
much so but uh yeah no I mean that's
what I'm
there this is an interesting question is
my point yes do we do it through a
commission probably not if we if we're
serious about exploring this idea or if
the sponsors are I'm not on this this
bill um I wouldn't have joined this this
sponsorship because I don't think that
this would be the right way to do it but
I do like the idea that somebody's
talking about exploring Alternatives
because we don't actually know if this
is the best outcome we're sticking with
the status quo bias because that's what
humans do we like the status quo we're
comfortable with it um but there might
devil we know the devil we know right
and and but you know it's possible the
devil we don't know is better and we
won't know that unless we studied it so
with that I will stop talking
representative
baros um I just want to say that it
seemed like for the people who were in
favor of this commission one of their
main concerns was the sale of liquor
going down so I don't think the answer
to that is privatization I think it's
looking at the marketing plan and it's
looking at the the product mix I mean
there was just an article in the New
York Times about how non-alcoholic
beverages sell those is soaring a lot of
them are sold in Liquor Stores um I'm
not a big drinker we found a
non-alcoholic wine that is absolutely
amazing so I think that it's more of a
marketing issue and and planning issue
than just dismantling the whole thing
which basically seems to be working so
that's my
thought any other disc representative
pus thank you chairman hun uh I'd like
to get back to the subject of the bill
it says establishing a commission to
study the
privatization not the marketing or
anything else of Liquor Commission so I
would like to move
itl okay moving right along okay all
right
so
second by representative hunt moves
inexpedient to legislate any discussion
on the
motion yes representative
Walts if it ain't broke don't fix it
well I mean I don't I would
say um when I first got elected they
used to have a rule that
um that that all rules had to be R had
to be reviewed every so often okay and
that and then and the same thing was
with
departments that every Department had to
we we would review the the role of that
department and and really feel see
whether they're doing it right or doing
and eventually we got rid of that
because it just seemed like a real
burden and nothing ever no one ever
change because everybody kind of stuck
with the devil they knew um I think in
terms of the the role of our Liquor
Commission is clearly we have a very
successful Liquor Commission as control
States go and and and but that I think
that um right now this is like the worst
sign to be doing it because um our
number one source of customers that are
outside the state of New Hampshire um
they changed the rules and they decided
that they're going to go with one big
company which when we did the marijuana
commission that was one of the fears
that people didn't like the idea that
that you would concentration of of
wealth and store store power be in one
individual company in this case
Massachusetts and I'm not going to
mention names again but in terms of that
they have uh dramatically changed our
customers that they are not coming up
from Massachusetts because they can just
go to Shrewsberry or go to Brockton or
all these other major metropolitan areas
in Massachusetts and and get the same
pricing we have um so that changes
things and then when you throw in the
fact that we have dry January and we
have the rise of non-alcohol and and
then it's to me it's like every every
week it's another Brewer who's going out
of business I mean it's just you know
it's it's you know the the mar Market
was saturated so things are really
changing and I to me the idea that we
should change our model now it seems
like a bad timing to me but I think that
um I certainly liked having this
discussion in our committee I think we
uh you know we can be fair and discuss
it and and uh but
then it was even a disagreement upon
between the sponsors on what they wanted
out of the committee and and one of the
sponsors didn't want to privatize at all
she she wanted she just wanted to bring
back the old system we had in which in
which the the finance committee had more
control over the commission so
um at this point I I I do agree with
that we should not pass it is buil
today yes absolutely um in thinking
about this the uh Governor just
established a committee to look all the
um all the agencies and this you know if
they go through the agencies this may
especially because it begins with a um
they they may actually you know look at
uh this possibility or try to do some
cost benefit analysis and perhaps they
would make a recommendation out of that
uh commission maybe that's something
that could be recommended to them but I
think it might happen by default right
but it is an a they'll start with L this
they're
L okay is the motion clear of
inexpedient to
legislate any any discussion on the
motion seeing none all those in favor
please raise your hand one two three
okay all
least okay removing the requirement that
on premise lcy serve food okay so the
sponsor is here um just so you know I'm
breaking all the rules to allow you to
uh testify so we will we will uh uh we
will say you're not testifying you're
sharing uh other things that you would
hope to have come up my first question
is did you watch the Youtube on the
hearing I did okay so let's say you're
you're responding to what you saw on the
YouTube yes so so I won't really get
into a testify I'm uh representative
hemway freshman of my m at Claremont
District Six uh Claremont Cy as my
Representatives um so this was brought
to me um by the city
uh in a way that would improve young um
retention young adult
retention because as it is right now
there is no night life for them to stay
around in this area they they go to
school right out of out of high school
or they go to college and then they they
take off and then they go to places
where there's something that's for them
to do in the evenings 9:00 10:
most places most cities uh towns uh the
streets are rolled up there's nothing
out there I remember back in the 80s
when I was when I was uh 17 years old
there was uh we had
nightclubs of course they was still tied
to Food Service but they had nightclubs
they had U and if it wasn't in New
Hampshire we'd go to
Vermont at 17 no so uh but
and that's what's happening right now
New Hampshire people were losing that
Revenue because they're going to Vermont
they're going to Maine they're going to
massachus and that's where they're
they're having their night life so this
isn't more about just drinking and
getting smashed and and you know uh
getting fights this is about having a
social environment for the young adults
and mid mid-age uh adults to have a
place to go socialize maybe listen some
music get out and have a dance or
whatever so this this is the premise of
this build basically is just
to
tourism adult uh retention in New
Hampshire because right now uh we're
still we're increasing in some young
adults but our our elderly the 60 65 my
age are still overrunning that young
adult age and we need to have that young
youth to manage our businesses and our
our Industries and bring the population
back up to where it needs to
be uh so I have some good news for you
um after 9:00 there is no food
requirement okay I I did not see that in
the bill that's no that's in the current
law yeah yeah current law current law
that there's that the food requirement
disappears at night okay however they
still have to provide
food prior to that even while that's
open open to my understanding is they
still need to provide food no after they
don't have to provide as long as it
$75,000 for the year know that's the
establish that's to be a lensee so one
of the testimony I know you since you
heard it was that um we had a testimony
from Mike Hummers who said that frankly
food is not particularly
profitable and so therefore um you know
they having having the ability for them
not you know to stay open late without
having to serve food is would be a good
thing right that can help bring in the
profitability uh but that you know that
um so what you're proposing is that
people in Claremont would like to see an
establishment that would be open prior
to 9:00 yes and and be theoretically
only served liquor correct and did the
restaurants in Claremont know that the
was being proposed I have not talked to
the restaurants right did did talk to
several other people within the right
around about how how would you feel if
you were a restaurant owner and all of a
sudden a bar opened next door that
didn't have a food requirement I was a
restaurant owner in Claremont yeah and
we had the we had the requirement to
have food same as everybody else right
um I think that if you were to allow a
restaurant to come in you would have
that mix of this would not be a
restaurant you we're allowing excuse
we're allowing the bar right so if you
allow bar to come in thank you if we
allowed a bar to come in and I think it
would complement the restaurant because
if they're there at uh you know 5:00 in
the afternoon you want to get something
to eat they'll come over to your
establishment they'll eat and then maybe
they'll go back to the bar they'll sit
at your bar and have it have some food
but it does create you know downtown CL
is dead yes right so and we're trying to
revitalize it so a way to revitalize It
Is by either putting in little food
establishments in there Andor having the
ability to have a individual bar in
there it's going to bring more people
it's a walking environment on on that
street and it would be great opportunity
for those little niche uh businesses to
fit in
there fair enough representative
BR thank you I mean is there any concern
about I mean it's been documented that
when people drink without eating their
level of intoxication goes up more
rapidly and so I'm concerned about
driving and that kind of thing so is
there have you thought about that aspect
yes representative burough uh so with
that we also provide two taxi companies
in there there's Ubers and everything in
there that proximity of there is is
close proximity to a lot of uh housing
in that area I'm probably less than a
mile from where where most of that
activity would take place I would walk
um I know a lot of other people that
walk to either the El allegion you know
uh so that they don't have to worry
about the driving piece um so
yes there was represent
hwood well excuse me uh thanks for
coming in I'm the one who presented your
bill last week or whatever it was um I
mean I listen I everybody here knows I'm
on board with this I put in a similar
but much less aggressive Bill last year
to try to do to move in this direction
um and I and I actually I I really do
agree with the idea that New Hampshire
has it's like it's like a slow moving
train wreck that we can see coming in
terms of our demographic problem here we
have the lowest birth rate in the
country we have the second oldest
population the country and what I hear
over and over again is that New
Hampshire is boring and I think we need
to make New Hampshire fun for younger
people and there's a reason why no it's
true I mean people come here on vacation
when I lived in Boston I I I used to
come up here to go skiing and go go to
my lakes and stuff like that but I
wouldn't come up here and be like oh
let's do a night out here like you would
in Portland OR Burlington or Providence
whatever so um sounds like a will you
believe but
uh my my question is just is a
subcommittee so you don't have to worry
there there not a hear good you it can
be an interactive conversation perfect
um thank you uh yeah so um have you do
you have do you know anybody who is I
mean it would be great if we I I know
people who would support this and I I
think that our job on the Commerce
Committee is not to Simply entrench the
incumbents but rather to tear down walls
to allow new businesses to thrive um
have you do you have people like you
said the city came to you is that like
the city counselor or is that a mayor
like who came to you just people who
live in the town the manager the manager
okay so the city manager came to you and
thought of this as an idea okay so it is
coming so he must be hearing it from
somebody in his community uh he's he's
talked to Lebanon Portsmith Keane
NASA and all these are favorable for
this AC yeah okay and that that's
interesting because I
think I'm going to tell you right now
you got some hurdles to get this through
I mean I I support it even if it gets
out of the house it probably won't go
much further but I I think that um I
think that I commend you for doing this
work knowing that it probably won't get
signed into law this year even if it
gets out of the house I would uh
encourage you to and I'll work with you
to try to build more of a coalition to
try to get this going because I I think
this is where New Hampshire needs to go
I think um you know I've lived in cities
that don't have these laws and they're
not coming apart at the seams um and I
think I think it's
oftentimes uh just the incumbent players
who own a restaurant who think it's
unfair that they've gone through one
thing but we're not are just because we
have a bad law in place that they maybe
wouldn't have participated in a decade
ago doesn't mean we shouldn't try to fix
it now and make it better for the future
otherwise we get stuck in this
inferior uh solution if you will so uh
happy to work with you in the future on
this and in this process as well
represent
Walsh thank you Mr
chairman uh I am all for making New
Hampshire grade
again uh had to get that in there I had
a question on uh line
26 uh section uh I believe it's 2
A1 the line actually I'm sorry it's line
30 on uh on the on the first page that
says the dining room shall not however
be used as a substitute for lounge
operations I mean we have a lot of small
restaurants throughout the state so you
know with the intention of free
enterprise free market situations I mean
they they may have just one dining room
and if they're looking for an
opportunity to so you're you're looking
at the current law okay yeah okay so in
terms of what the bill does is the cross
out starting on page uh one there's a a
cross out at times as food is available
cross out there and the cross out so his
bill is the cross outs yes so it it
would remove that requirement that they
would Lounge right he's not adding
anything new he's only Crossing out
what's in the current law I get that but
but this line is not crossed out that
means it stays that that means it stays
in the law that's Cent law and and I
understand stays there I understand that
but I'm you think it should go be
deleted yes oh that's what I'm
out because there's a lot of small tiny
restaurants throughout New Hampshire
that may only have one dining room and
so here it's saying the dining room
shall
not be used as a substitute for lounge
operations why not let it be used for
lounge
operations uh I I guess I I missing yeah
delve
into at the full service concur with
that the I think that's related to the
full service license I I think that but
that's that under our current law at 9
o'clock that that that dining room can
be a b right so after nine they can be
used as a b in current law current law
okay and that that's just set up so I
believe and I always look at my
enforcement but they seem to have their
backs to
me hello Liquor Commission we have a
question I assume that's sex you don't
have to come over just just say yes or
no when I say things
okay you say I'm all wrong and then you
need to that I believe this this section
that she's referring to is our license
that for that full liquor license that
will'll have the the dining room then
can be serve just liquor after 9 o' okay
that's just the that's just the
description of the lensey so
theoretically and we haven't that we
haven't really even delved it into this
bill the question is how much should
that bar license
be because um the last time I sponsored
this legis
uh the issue was that if you were going
to just issue a bar if you're just going
to create a bar bar um then this would
uh need a an expensive license because
the Liquor Commission would have to
spend a little extra time sure on that
facility and uh off the top of my head I
believe the number was $10,000 license
for the year okay so in other words
notwithstanding that they we had to make
up you know whether we're making up for
the food but that the enforce ment
division would say you are creating a
magnet for uh people for being over
served and that's why the issue was a
high an expensive license I I I could
probably see that for a larger
establishment but for a for
establishment that's that's maybe a
th000 square feet or or 800 square feet
a hole in the wall yep yep I think
10,000 would be a little excessive that
is true is
true but
okay so are you all said represent yep
spear we do a lot of mandating here from
the state down to the municipalities why
are we not considering even making this
an option I don't know that every town
necessarily wants to do it or feels that
they can do it or feels that they've got
it police and and the rest of it the
whole you know everything that goes
along with that right well only to the
extent to what as I described that the
liquor enforcement I don't mean liquor
enforcement I mean the DUI and all the
rest of it and the taxi cabs and the and
the Ubers and whatever I mean it should
be optional it shouldn't be
mandated uh I don't I don't know I don't
know we mandate any of that you by by
changing the law exactly the way it's
written so to enable a community to say
okay we um to enable to enable community
a town to say that they want to wave the
food
requirements okay they want to wave that
section of the bill in other words this
this amendment is that they want to wave
it the question still comes up to that
are they also waving liquor
enforcement because liquor enforcement
would contend that that dis
establishment would be a magnet for over
serving and that they would need to
spend a little more time visiting that
establishment where where does this say
it's an enabling law as opposed to you
no I'm not saying I'm saying you're
proposing that Amendment yes you're
proposing an amendment to just make it
enabling okay but and maybe we can't
even do that but certainly not to make
it a
mandate right okay but right so so I'm
just pointing out to you that if we were
to making this enabling that the town
the city of Cl it's a city right and the
City of Claremont that they the uh they
could vote to um make
it that that that would not uh make it
uh that the Liquor Commission would not
enforce the food
requirement the LI commission say well
that's great you save a little money and
us having to come in and audit the food
sales but we're we would be very
concerned is you're now a magnet for
over consump you know over serving and
therefore we need need to have send our
our enforcement agency there more often
so how are you going to make up for that
and that would go back to the licensing
fee so representative pus thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um in the Claremont area which
you're representing uh do you know how
many social clubs are in that area and
as a followup are you aware that most of
them have
a
bar thank
you
um excuse me that's fine um that's close
close um there are there are several
there's the oak ofion the the and yes I
know they all have bars um they also
serve food on occasion they have food
they don't have the the same food
requirement they don't have the same
food requirement either but those been
there for and and that's in the bill or
not in this bill but it's in the in the
liquor laws it says that a private club
can have liquor only that's that's
already established it's a private club
so it's not just available to every
citizen because some of those have
requirements BFW you have to have
veteran Legion you have to be someone
had to be in the veteran um I'm not sure
about the Jewish polish or the Polish
American Club you have maybe have to
have something like that so yes those
those establishments are there but
they're not they're limited to a
specific sect of the citizens and and
this bill is not just for Claremont it
would be all all of New Hampshire too
so but what she was representative spear
was asking how would you feel if we just
made it enabling um at this point I I I
think that we were we were hoping to
just do it as but that may be a
concession that I would definitely look
at and I think enabling allowing a
municipality sorry allowing a
municipality to decide whether they want
to have that type of establishment and
there would be upon them but I think the
Planning and Zoning would also help to
kind of narrow down where those things
would go okay represent Herbert we used
to have a a very um
robust probably a bar business in the in
the state on the private club level yes
and I don't know why I don't know why
they stopped it well I don't know I mean
I'm a member of something called the
East Side Club okay I don't know that's
not a sect and you know we're just on
the east side so uh and and and they
have a a a kitchen that they don't even
use that is correct so I'm I'm I'm
curious at one point in time what you're
want to do was allowed in in the state
but no longer I don't and I I don't know
why it isn't that way yeah I I I don't
know if it was allowed or if it was the
because theyve met their
$75,000 that no they didn't have that
requirement my memory was that at some
point in time we just grandfathered all
the current clubs but could someone
today you have to come to the mic sorry
why don't you grab one of these mics
over here you want me to NOP you stay
can you have a seat they they could
there's different requirements for each
license type so right in this
conversation we've talked about several
different license types and what would
require this you can still create a
social club today there are certain
requirements that you'd have to do to
establish that what would be the
threshold that the City of Claremont
could not allow a club to you know what
it could get into a process of allowing
a club that is open to the public and
and and and attractive to young people
so there are no social clubs that are
technically open to the public they are
all members only clubs and members can
sign in guests right um that can attend
with them so there is no Club in the
terms that you're talking about at the
East Side club or the social club the
vfw's those are all private clubs which
is why they don't have a food require
one of the reasons they don't have a
food requirement um there's there's two
in Matt maybe you can um help with this
as well so I remember I'm old enough to
remember that in in
Utah they didn't have liquor
establishments at all they had private
clubs and they've had a statue that
allowed you to just join the club the
day you walked in the
door you can join anybody can join the
club it's just members only so so yes
you could walk into a so we could we
could mirror that in terms of if
Claremont wanteded to to have a a club
per se under the club stat statute that
uh you're there's no uh timeline about
joining the club that anybody could join
the club that you know and walk in that
day in terms of how you become a member
that would actually be up to the
individual Club as to as open their
practices and policies on on how you
become a member of the club there are
certain requirements in terms of
Licensing the club um if you're you know
the vfw's or um American Legions correct
you have to be part of the the national
fraternal organization corre there's
certain nonprofit clubs that can be you
have an do you have to have an
affiliation if you the club what's its
affiliation I believe the e is a
nonprofit oh it's just a nonprofit but
you have to be established as a
nonprofit for a certain you to have a
nonprofit purpose ahead of time correct
and there's and there's certain
timelines that you have to I don't have
I can certainly look them up that
there's certain timelines you have to
stay open and be be um established as
that you can't be just the weekends
correct no meaning meaning to to get the
liquor license you have to actually
establish yourself you the the non The
Entity had to exist for a period of time
correct sorry three years three years
been nonprofit for three years so that
that you could have some organization
that's in Clermont that's been around
for three years that they could uh
create a club and they would be free
from the food
requirement right but there there are
none and and again this isn't just about
Claremont this is about every every
municipality in New Hampshire um I just
use Claremont as an example because of
the the Uptown is is needs to be
revitalized so right and that was that
was an option but this goes for every
every municipality in New Hampshire and
I and so there is a cocktail license
also that does not require food but you
have to have 6,000 square feet if I
remember right of usable no that's not
no cocktail L does not have a square
foot requirement there's there's one
that's square foot is 6,000 usable
feet there's area maybe are you thinking
of a ballroom that's 500 seats Ballroom
license Ballroom license that that's uh
okay that's seating for 500 yeah yeah of
open area that doesn't include your bar
and everything so that's a pretty pretty
large establishment so but we're we're
we're looking at just targeting you know
a smaller or you know a a middle siiz
nightclub you know those types those
types of things that would allow
a Congregation of people to go and enjoy
music or or dance and then socialize all
right I I guess the problem I have in
visualizing this is
that is it's really I mean there
obviously Manchester NASA
Portsmith has the type of establishments
you're looking
for okay are they in terms of magnet and
the magnets for young people all
right the problem is is that a they have
the
population okay but more importantly in
my mind they have the
colleges that the people are looking for
night life right and to think that you
could uh that just to open up a
small Speak Easy small establishment in
Claremont and and Lord knows on Main
Street there's plenty of great locations
they could do that you're you're looking
you want to make sure you it's got have
a dance floor or stage and you know you
want to have and get the bands but to
get to be a magnet the having food or
not having food seems to the least of
your
problems it seems to me is is how where
are the population you're drawing from
how what are you where are they coming
from I mean Dartmouth is like at least
45 minutes away right right uh yeah
roughly okay and I know Keen State's GNA
be you know have so you don't even you
know the the establishments you know in
terms of what you're going to do to draw
people it's an interesting
concept um but I I I just I just don't
see how it would work but so so uh as it
is right now those people that would
probably come there are already going
over to bont they're going over to to
other emo they're probably going to oimo
yeah yeah absolutely I mean I've been
there sure yeah I've been I've been to
they've had some they have some bands up
there and it's not always just about
having a dance floor you know it's
probably just a space big enough you
have a a small you know musician in
there or you know U or just play some
music in there just just to have an area
where you know you're not sitting at a
round table or or sitting in a booth and
and having a discussion you know over
all the other you know just just a a
much more relaxed environment than in a
restaurant because in a restaurant if
you're sitting you're going out there
for a social event you're sitting there
hanging around you're you're costing
that waiter or waitress money because
they're not turning those tables over so
you can't just sit there and and
and stay there for three hours having a
conversation you you want to comment on
that I would thank you for the
opportunity Mr chairman um I I don't
want to lose focus on the reason why
food is part of establishments I know
representative you and I have had
several conversations about this last
session um as I testified in the last
meeting uh or in the full session the
burnoff rate of alcohol is 015 an
hour um we're looking at food as being a
deterrent for an establishment which I
can't wrap my head around that concept
um I appreciate totally what the
representative is saying and thank you
for that congrat congratulations um at
the at the same time food has always
been you've heard me testify on this
before the coffee filter for slowing
down the absorption rate of alcohol in
the body we're looking to keep you guys
have me in my position to keep our
communities in the industry safe that
was Paramount in every conversation that
I've had with every one of you um
haven't had it with your new members yet
but at the same time with the governor's
office we are keeping people safe our
model is a safe model as we testified
before but to look at the the ingestion
of food as being a deterrent for having
the the younger that I as you all know
because I've testified to it people like
my daughter coming to an establishment
they actually start their nights with
having dinner and a glass of wine so the
food is actually drawing them to the
establishment not pushing them away from
The Establishment I'm sure Mike um uh
has some comments about this um because
I can see he has comments about this but
but he he did in the public area I don't
want to lose focus on food being a a uh
critical factor in slowing down the
absorption of alcohol into the
bloodstream and
and that actually equals to negative
effects negative incidents on our
Highway negative effect effects in in
the establishments that are owned um it
just gives another opportunity to slow
that down it to your uh by the
responsible service but you're not
controlling the absorption because each
and every one of our metabolisms are
different so that's an unknown how quick
that's going to happen and and it's a
scary slippery slope it really is so um
that's my two cents um as I'm listening
to all the
testimony great represent s thank you so
um when you were talking to him a minute
ago you were saying how you don't see
how a change in this law might help
Claremont you know you don't see that
they have the population to sort of
support some of the establishments he's
talking about but I would argue Mr
chairman that it is not our job to try
to get in the minds of what a business
owner may or may not do to to be
successful in whatever Town they're
looking at across the state our job is
to enable them to be successful in the
state that is the job of our Commerce
Committee and I think perhaps right now
some of the things that you're thinking
of wouldn't work in Claremont but maybe
they would in the future maybe it would
start off with something that would
evolve as they became successful as more
people got attracted to the town because
there's exciting things going on like
this isn't like you hit a switch and
boom Clan Ron has like the most vibrant
downtown in the state I mean nobody's
nobody's suggesting that they do have a
speak easy though I've been to it um but
but I but I think I think we sometimes
get caught up in what we think a
business will do what kind of business
model will be successful that's not our
job our job is to allow the and
entrepreneurs to be set free to figure
out what they want to do and what's
going to be successful I think that
should be first and foremost on our
thinking of things with respect to the
safety I mean I I get it all I can say
is I I've lived in communities that
don't
other states that don't require food
Montana Massachusetts Illinois Germany
I've lived at all these places and I
mean I don't know that it's the world is
that much more unsafe in those
respective places than it is in New
Hampshire I still think there's drunk
driving going on here last I looked uh
New Hampshire's middle of the pack for
drunk driving it's not like it's we'
found the secret to get low levels of
drunk driving um we know that we have
the highest alcohol consumption or
purchases in the in the country per
capita largely distorted by
Massachusetts coming over and buying it
before you cut me off I understand that
um so what I'm saying is
is I think I think giving more
opportunities is generally better and
this allows for that I think to the
extent that there there needs to be a
higher fee I I'm on board with a higher
fee to help the Liquor Commission do
what they need to do like that's that
seems reasonable to me I mean if if if
if what they're saying is true and and I
I have no reason to believe it's not
that these these establishments could
require extra policing then that's
that's something we should considering
this and then my final point would
be with respect to food we already have
no food regulations after 9 o00 and the
world doesn't end after 9:00 you know I
I agree with what um what the chief just
said with respect to people like to go
out to places sometimes food is the
attraction they go there but sometimes
maybe they want to go to dinner and then
they want to go to the little Club next
door well you know those those two
aren't necessarily competitors as much
some places don't want to be more than
what they are now which is a restaurant
that sells alcohol until 9: and then
they close down some places want to be
something different and our laws don't
allow that and I think that there's no
reason to think that the world can't
exist with both being complimentary to
each other rather than competitors to
each other and that seems to be what
we're acting as if it's like if you have
this then all these restaurants have to
close down because they won't be
sucessful I just don't buy that that
that isn't how it works in most places
see that's where you're wrong because
all the places you
mentioned limit the amount of liquor
licenses that are available in those
towns that's their governor that's how
they control it in New Hampshire anybody
could get a liquor license you can have
a town you can have a section of town
where every business is a liquor you
know is selling liquor and lots of
entertainment and I would say that's the
area where people would would be
attracted to go to because it's got so
many of those little places all close
together with respect Mr
chairman in Montana the one we talked
about last week right quite familiar
with it because when I was in grad
school there one of the one of my
colleagues who was in the same class as
me wrote his whole thesis on Montana's
ridiculous cast Medallion system right
exactly so
you say that's where I'm wrong but the
reality of it is there are plenty of
restaurants in Boseman Montana where I
went to school in every other town in
New Hampshire where there are
restaurants that serve alcohol and then
there are just straight up bars now if
what you're saying is true and and the
cap on the number of licenses would lead
to just one or the other there's also
restaurants that don't tell alcohol so
like there are business models that work
that require alcohol and that don't
require alcohol or that
you know could be either way and and
I've seen that in every place that I've
lived same thing when I lived in Chicago
I don't actually understand I don't know
the liquor laws in Chicago but when I
lived in Chicago yeah there was there
were restaurants that sell small amounts
of alcohol but that's not their primary
business but they probably make you know
money on on the the mixed drink that
they sell and then there's the places
that just sell alcohol
and it's it hasn't migrated to just
primarily alcohol serving establishments
entirely with all the poor businesses
going out of business so I don't agree I
don't think I'm wrong I think I've my
experience living in multiple places you
see a even with a cap on licenses you
see a
vibrant uh industry of places that don't
even sell alcohol and are doing just
fine just selling food and selling food
into places that only sell
alcohol for example Uptown Lounge in
uptown chicagoon is not Chicago okay I'm
not claiming that it is where that's
what I'm saying this the idea is this
was an economic
Innovation for a small town that's
looking for how how do we you know spur
you know spur the economy and in this
case was how do we get more young people
to want to stay in Claremont okay well I
you know I I right now if you ask me
what claremont's problem is is Claremont
has very high property tax rates okay
and and
so why would any young person want to
live in Claremont I'm sorry that's New
Hampshire has very high property taxes
no Claremont is claremont's tax rate is
three times
my but but I but I think I think I'm not
saying that this is going to solve
clam's problem but there are a lot of
reasons why New Hampshire is getting old
older faster than every other state in
the country there's a lot of reasons and
we can go into those what I'm saying is
one of the reasons is that New Hampshire
is not considered a fun place to go and
have NTI Sor there are a lot of people
in and Portsmouth would disagree with
you I would like to meet these people
cuz I go to Portsmith and everything
closes down at midnight like I've gone
there there there it's not it's like i'
I I was I went to the young Dems I went
to the young Dems event in Portsmith two
summers ago I I spoke at it and then
afterwards went out with a bunch of
people who were from Portsmith and like
oh yeah it's like it see everybody talks
about Port literally this is what people
said to me everybody talks about
Portsmith being like the cool town of
New Hampshire and it's it's still
relatively sleep nothing's really open
after midnight and I saw with my own
eyes so what I'm saying is I understand
this is not a high priority for you but
and it's and I'm I don't even let's just
change the subject here's because you're
I get it here's the point that I'm
making and that is that he wants to
they're are proposing a radical change
in our law this is a radical change we
haven't talked about what about the off-
premise lienes who are going to have the
food requirement they're going to say us
too we want to get rid of the food
requirement
okay we're talking about something that
it was instit it's part of our initial
statutes it's been on the books since
1934 and to throw that baby out all
right with the concept that we're going
to be some kind of economic engine to me
doesn't make sense that's all I'm saying
but at at the same time I understand
where you're coming from is that boy we
need to do you know wouldn't it be great
to do something what why not just be
enabled
okay why not just let people do what
they want to do and let's hope for the
best and I'm sorry I'm I'm not there I'm
not you know I you were at one point you
tried to do this you told me 10 years
ago or whatever what has changed in 10
years what's changed in 10 years is I
had my head handed to me on the house
floor that was you know what happened
every restant it's not because you saw
the light it's because somebody attacked
you every rest no I didn't tack that bad
way I'm saying that the bill died it
mean I didn't even get a 100 votes okay
that that it was overwhelmingly rejected
by the house okay and that and maybe you
could say things are changed but that
was the second time I had sponsored it
okay so yeah I'm I'm not ready to to put
my name or go and support a bill when I
know full well that the reality is that
we H we have a system now in place and
it's for a reason and the reason is as
the commission said is that we we want
people to eat food we want them to have
food and so the idea that we want to
have a bar bar and you know was fine and
I mean I remember the days when when I
was at Boston University and yeah
Cambridge closed at one and Boston was
two so yeah we all raced back over to
Boston to drink drink extra hour had
this debate last year okay so mean I
understand all that but but in terms of
of passing what I consider very radical
legislation um in terms of our statue is
on on this economic concept um I'm not
I'm not there that's all and that and
that's what the subcommittee is about is
we all are we're working through we're
allowed to talk about what we personally
feel and and uh they're different from
the you know the
actual introduction the bill in the
hearing so I'm just saying is you know
I'm I'm not there that's all I'm saying
I mean I think the reason that people
get the people the reason get so upset
is is because they have a moat around
their buildings or their businesses now
and they don't want somebody to come in
and be different and their fear is that
some of them which some of them might go
out of business but many of them would
stay in business they just they'll just
change like this is how it works
like that logic of changing it suggests
that we
have the it suggests that this is an
inferior law that they wouldn't have
abided by had it been different but
because it was they had to do it and we
tied their hands well that's not a
reason to keep something on the books
okay fair enough representative Burrows
thanks I have a question for the Liquor
Commission because I share your concern
about the food and this may be a dumb
question but what's the definition of
food would you feel more comfortable if
a bar had popcorn and um checks mix and
pretzels and all that that was my bill
last time we literally signed that bill
last time oh okay I must have been
sleep they want real food they want real
real food real okay we're not feeding
carb carbs and and salt yeah thank you m
CH I have a would you believe um I was
in the Air Force for a bunch of years I
spent three years in
Europe uh I was either stationed in or
temporary duty to 16 different countries
over in Europe uh I went into a a guest
house
penson uh every establishment had food
every establishment there were no bars
that I know in Europe and I ate and
drank in a lot of places and I just
drank in a bunch of places that had food
but there was no mandate to buy the food
so that's my would you believe
okay uh I think I'll make a make the
motion uh to inexpedient to legislate
second by representative pusc is there
any discussion on the
motion okay all those in favor of the
motion please please raise your hand one
two three four five six and those
opposed okay no I didn't count him not
only I didn't count okay let me count
again so those opposed those opposed
oppos on the committee you for opposed
right I'm going revers now I'm going
reverse those who are opposed to
inexpedient to legislate two people okay
those in
support okay one 2
3 4 oh I oh I see what the problem was
was that because you're here now I'm
here now so so so you're not you're not
voting that's where my number got into
okay so it's five to
two
good it's you both voted the same way
anyways so we're all set okay I give Mr
see
15 all right that's that's uh it for the
liquor
am
e
you know I guess I should I never times
no you don't you don't bother with times
okay um well all I do is I usually you
know take I a note who's on the
have
melier
Herbert
Co no yeah
no
it no that's Sal excuse
never
e
okay just want to make sure I have the
the right committee here all right so
this is the business banking and we have
Keith Ammon melier Herbert spear hunt
right
okay all right uh Keith there's any
particular order you want to take these
on see who's in the room do we
so I I think maybe the easiest one to
dispatch is the 3 310 which is the study
commission study commission okay and my
recollection is we were going to discuss
duties and uh members right well get I
get um I don't know I had
this it's going back and forth about 302
with the state
treasurer invest would you be really
upset if we just take that and put it
part of the commission have them figure
out how to do that I think that's too
much for that commission to it's already
got stable token and real world asset
regulations those are two huge things
right would you want it to be the only
the only issue is that that you know
well I'll take digital asss and leave
the in uh precious metals but then I
found out that no state has passed
precious metals yet yeah so then I'm s
of saying you know so this is if we're
going to you're going to start with 302
yeah let's just start with 302 all right
so this is my I can pass this out okay
uh hold on a
second this is my proposal for what to
okay okay so theoretically there's only
a limited amount so people need to
share I printed eight so so
theoretically the committee committee
nine so so I'll share share mine with
John it didn't it didn't um change it
did he no this is a oh it was this is
us it's basically stripping some of the
bill oh okay got all red yeah so strike
all the strike throughs would be
eliminated so I can go over it on on the
sure okay all right
here I'm just I'm just I'm cheing out
the red lines so I can speak to the
proposal if you'd like yeah go ahead
please so there are um there are some
ancillary things in here that I think
are kind of uh to too far ahead and I I
don't think they they make sense at this
point in time okay and that would be so
I'm on page two line five we'll remove
so page two line five uh striking stable
coins line seven striking staking line
10 striking staking as a service and
that's related to line 16 removing
stable coin and line 25 removing that
the state treasure May engage in lending
or staking I think that's
probably those things are too far in the
future and don't make any sense if we
want to simplify this this bill we
remove those right and then my my final
proposal is on line 18 I think 10% is
too high if we made that 5% or 2% you
maximum so that that that would be my
proposal something lower so you just
right at this point you just crossed out
and and you haven't put a new number in
I it's in the comment but it didn't
print out com whatever number lower than
10 we some lower percentage yeah okay it
could be 2% you know right well I guess
represent spear is going to talk about
is is
liquidity can I make a comment or yes go
ahead but I was jumping the gun on very
difficult to hear down at this end of
the room okay we have two types of uh
funding at at some point you could say
two types of funding we have our uh
budget State's budgets and we have our
Reserve gold is not immediately
it's not a liquid
uh a liquid commodity or uh if if you do
it as an ETF it's liquid if you do it as
a as a as gold bullion it's not liquid
and I don't have a problem with putting
it into the reserve where I have a
problem is putting it into the regular
budget operating budget if we put it in
the operating budget we have a pro we
have rents we have salaries we have
medical we have all kinds of things that
get paid every week every month right
cash flow yes right but but I see
strategic Reserve
established so is that what you mean by
Reserve you know like the rainy day fund
is that what the the reserve
establishment is the rainy day fund can
can I just say that's really just a a
marketing term for this bill it's uh
it's not an actual Reserve unless the
treasurer decides to make one right so
we're not we're not mandating it we're
just giving her the tools
could I make a couple how can that work
okay yes
represent first thing is um I don't
think this any of this would go in an
operating budget at all no it can't be
no it can't be secondly um is it even
necessary to have um a 2% or 5% limit um
I would think that that the investment
committee would make a decision so I
think I don't think there needs to be
any
maximum limit are there at
all you know they're supposed to be
fiduciaries I think they could figure it
out well I'm I'm just trying to figure
out what this is first so we don't have
a strategic Reserve now right so this
thing is establishing one it's so this
is being talked about at the federal
level and many state levels are talking
about uh H having States and and the the
federal government have the ability
to weather in inflation right so the US
dollar has lost 20% of its purchasing
power since the year
2020 and that's that's it's we've had
hyperinflation so not hyper but more
than we've seen in our
lifetime depending on how old we are can
I pass out one more thing you don't have
to read this whole thing I I just want
to understand what we're doing here okay
so I now see two things I see strategic
Reserve established yeah and then in
this section those are all definitions
right so then I get down
to um Roman numeral 2 on page
two and and using our favorite
notwithstanding yeah which then means
you know for me that John here's the law
notwithstanding is this is where we
start and in here it talks about the
fun does that already
exist well that would be the the rainy
day fund this is the reny day fund
okay they invest so this is that so to
if I understand correctly this is not
the General operating
budget okay right I don't think this is
fund a comment on that rainy day fund
remember your comment was you're okay
thought it could be Pension funds too
right which is I just want to point out
one thing about the rainy day fund two
years ago when I started here two and a
half years ago it was $400 million today
it's $250 million
and we are facing some bdet uh budget
shortfalls and all kinds of things
facing who knows what's going to happen
just just caution you that it's not just
sitting there doing nothing you know I
mean caution me to say that maybe by the
end of the budget when we get to July 1
it might be zero it could be zero yeah
it could be zero which means we can pass
the legislation but it doesn't mean
anything because there's no money in it
no I just want to just wanted you to be
aware it's not something that's sitting
out there totally safe got it but I I I
would say that this isn't telling them
to go and do this and if there's little
money in the in in that rainy day fund
they're not going to do it if they need
the liquidity but this is down the road
one one thing different about that right
now the treasure we have is very
competent but any day she could be made
an offer to go into the into the private
sector or she could go to Federal
whatever and we could get somebody who
in in here who's a cowboy so we need to
be able to at least
without knowing what the future is
something I I think that there's
probably an investment committee and I
also think that we probably Farm some of
the stuff
out okay so that correct Keith I believe
so can I just I have one more thing I
didn't want to overwhelm everybody with
paperwork when we met with the treasurer
she gave us this print out I made copies
I made eight copies I didn't realize it
was nine on the commiss commission the
committee um if you look on page three
if you don't have one I'll pass mine
down
I think I have one here pass okay page
three uh that's a
different page three is the list of
approved uh Investments according to
statute that and what we're trying to do
is add add to that that list right right
that's right this is all worm fuzzy did
there
pass Mr chairman
okay there's two two things observations
you have to speak to the mic not to me
there's two observations that uh the
budget is ridiculous this is not the
budget about this this particular
legislation at this particular time and
that is that agement my understanding is
we're running
a $500 million hole right now that was
out of the finance committee so I I'm
I'm finding
it difficult
to do anything like this uh when when we
have another very very important job and
that is where are we going to well we
can't find $500 million by the way right
so I'm I've already written an essay
that means this legislation is
meaningless because we will have no
money in this fund anyways but that
should not be a reason to stop us from
doing it I think the context is
important but fix oh so that we're in
denial about our our our deficit
situation if we're putting going forward
and trying to do something Progressive
and that might might not happen for
another 5 to 10 years we shouldn't be
doing this because we need to deal with
the problem at hand I think we have more
difficult issues that we need to deal
but this is not a difficult issue
because it's a non issue if we don't
have any money then
then then then the state treasurer won't
do anything well I'm I'm predicting
that's what's going to happen there you
go yes representative um so we we none
of us can foresee the future um but we
can you know have the best plans for
meeting the challenges of the future
there's another aspect to passing this
bill even if the treasur doesn't do
anything for a few years with it uh and
that send it sends a signal that New
Hampshire is open to digital assets and
uh there there is a race happening right
now between States because a lot of
people you know believe count me as one
of them that digital assets are going to
they're going to overtake our
traditional Financial system they're
going to the innovation coming out of
that space is going to um you know I
don't want to say supplant but we'll
have to adapt to it right it's it's
change that pretty much cannot be
stopped and passing this bill would send
a signal that New Hampshire is you know
a jurisdiction that understands that so
there's there's some symbolic you know
benefit to
it
okay a question for Keith yes Keith I I
I just very briefly glanced that that at
that but everything in there is fixed
income I didn't see any equities at all
I mean no equities are not in there
pardon but again this is this is under
her
current well if she's going to be
allowed to invest in in gold or silver I
think that they should certainly have
equities in there as well well she's got
corporate
bonds I mean this is it's ridiculously
conservative
there's a lot of good information
there's a lot of good information in
that packet um I apologize for not
getting it to you sooner but I can uh
email it it does have mutual funds but
they're they're fixed income mutual
income right so theoretically everything
in this list is pretty liquid so we're
year lose money in terms of Interest or
pardon where where are we going to be
losing uh inflation value you know
right and but this is what we use to get
rating so what Keith is saying is is
that the reality is no we're not this is
never going to happen even a cowboy that
I can't imagine we the legislature cuz
we are the ones who choose the state
treasure I can't believe a cowboy or or
the we would lose our mind and bring in
a cowboy to be our state treasur but
that at the end of the day the state
treasur to maintain their their bond
rating there she's going to ignore this
legislation but he's saying that if we
pass it it sends a message that New
Hampshire uh wants to be on the front
Lin so that if the if things were to
happen in the future that digital assets
cuz we're one of the first states to do
digital assets right how many states
have digital assets now we have a good
reputation uh in that space as being a
jurisdiction that's friendly so it' be
Texas Wyoming New Hampshire okay and a
few other states terms of in the
portfolio no no state has it no state
has it no State uh might venture to say
May never have it but that's not the
point that he's making the point he's
making is that if we put in there and
say that the treasure the ne
availability that we could in the future
of all of a sudden the the bond councils
or you know who are Moody is that is
that the rating if Moody suddenly
changed their mood about digital assets
that we would be
strategically ahead of everybody else to
go ahead and take it advantage of it I I
we we talk about being in the Forefront
and eight states have passed laws you
are in the forr to set up the commiss
back to set up the same commission that
we're going to be talking about next
right and did it two years
ago I think that the times of saying
that we're going to be in the absolute
Forefront well I mean you know one can
can I ask or can I inject one other
thing I can't hear anything uh so I'm
talking closer to my mic is that
sounding okay sounds better to me all
right um there's a lot of changes
happening in Washington DC right now as
we speak on this issue and the LA the
landscape is going to open up one of the
things that could benefit our the local
economy with a bill such as this is our
state Banks may very likely be able to
Charter these digital Assets in the very
near future like you know within the
next six to 12 months is my is my guess
and that's that allows our our our
banking system in the state to adopt you
know these new things so that's another
thing to consider um but wouldn't that
be determined that in our state uh State
Bank chapter we would have to then allow
that in their section of the
law because that's you know rather than
a federally charged bank that if it's a
State chared Bank don't don't we have
these kind of same kind of parameters
and what they're allowed to invest
do we have the bank commissioner here
today
yes I'm Seth saki the general counc at
the banking Department yeah there there
are Provisions in RSA 383b that that
provide that sort of guidance for banks
okay so do we we don't have digital
assets at this point in there those are
not specified in 383b okay so at this
point they would not be available to a
bank I'm I'm not prepared to say it that
they're not they're not they're not
specified in the statute
question
um we have a very difficult problem uh
we're in a hole the hole is I understand
in the order of $500 million
what kind of bond rating do you think we
would get in that
situation so as the bank that's that's
beyond my expertise I I wouldn't be able
to comment on
that so you're you're asking you're
asking the wrong person yeah
so
okay yeah uh you want to spell it your
name for her sure it's first name is
Seth last name is Zaki Z is in zebra o r
okay I have a
question yes go ahead I have a question
for
kit uh kit I did go over the notes and
everything you have given by us uh my
question is there are five states which
are in
the uh cryptocurrency okay Wyoming Floyd
Texas Arizona and New York so my
question is have we done any kind of a
research whether they are making any
progress or it's good for them it is all
whatever I read uh through my uh
internet or whatever the stuff is on
various uh boards various groups I don't
see they are all confused they really do
not know whether they have taken the
right decision or not so if we are
getting
into this and we are telling that okay
we are going to allow cryptocurrency we
are going to allow this concept and we
as a Commerce Committee decided to go
and move forward with
it isn't that we have to prove that that
by looking at the progress of the states
that they have done this thing correct
they have done this thing wrong so we
are going to do something better so I
really don't see any kind of research
getting into this bill that we need to
push the Commission in because we have a
lot of things to do so my concern is so
you don't you don't like the bill no not
like the bill my concern is
basically how we can try to position
ourself that New Hampshire being the
sixth state in trying to Advocate the
digital uh cryptocurrency see that yes
we learn from these five states and we
will be doing something like this so
that the commission has some kind of a
goal to achieve because we are just
pushing it on the commission and we are
saying that please figure it
out so I don't think we're talking about
the commission bill right now we're
talking about we're talking about the
other Bill we're talking about 302 the
state treasur Bill okay yeah so you're
talking about investing it right but I
think let me let me be frank about both
of these bills okay
that the both of these bills
are we're we're actually not doing
anything other than saying these are
things we can consider the commission is
that we're giving them the task to
figure out that if we were going to do
something what would be the necessary
legislative structure we need to create
so they're going to be figuring out what
what is out there what is good for us so
the commission is going to do what
you're asking for which is to go figure
that out okay and then come back to us
and they can come back and say nothing
don't don't bother they can come back
and say Here's what you need to do
legislatively that seems to be working
in other
states or here's something that we think
might work you know that we think should
work will work and it will fit into the
guidelines of how we operate in the
state of New Hampshire and this bill
this is is absolutely the state
treasurer the state treasurer has an
obligation when she swore when we voted
her in and you raise your right hand she
had an obligation to best to
preserve our Reserve our our funds
reserves and not make any crazy
Investments so she hands out this flyer
which says this is the guidelines that
what she's investing into and as
representative M leer pointed out is
that these are very safe
instruments to the point that they're
too safe and they're really they're
really not going to you know you know
they're not they're not breaking out of
the mold of anything that is creative
such as investing in precious metals or
digital assets let alone buying IBM
stock okay so that because you know she
you know in the end of the day today
what the standards for her when we talk
about the Secretary of Treasury is the
standards is
Moody and Moody will will you know that
what they're going to come in and look
at what where the money is and what you
know she's doing and saying you know
here's your bond rating based on that so
in this case what we're what we're doing
with both of these things these
legislation is that we're trying to be
foresighted to say is okay how do we how
do we make people think and feel warm
fuzzies about New Hampshire being the
Delaware of
Corporations you okay the place where we
would want to do business where we want
to be incorporated where we want to
business because the state is
open-minded to look at these potential
these digital assets and look at these
future is that good yeah that's a good
explanation I just want to remind uh
remind myself actually that uh on you'll
see on page two of 30 House Bill 302
page two line
15 there's a a minimum size market
capitalization for the digital asset so
it's 500 billion which is a very um
large number yes again you're don't
speak to people speak to them I need my
microphone louder yes anybody in the uh
eat the control room
there yeah um on House Bill 302 page two
line uh 15 there's a a minimum number
for a digital assets so we're not
talking we're talking about 500 billion
I'm gonna I'm GNA say we're talking
about world class digital assets we're
not talking about the junk at the bottom
right we're talking
about we can't buy any Trump coins no we
the treasure would not be able to buy
Trump coins so and it's a very liquid
Global Market so there there's no I I
don't think there's any you know real
concern about liquidity in a market that
size it's it's over $2 trillion doll
right now Bitcoin right but it it
doesn't prevent let's say there's some
other coins that are on the Ascension
like ethereum and salana are two of the
the upand cominging ones neither of them
satisfi that Threshold at this point in
time but maybe at you know a few years
into the future they may but that that
market cap is uh important to keep in
mind
okay I have
question if it's about the budget
Chris if you if you're going to start
talking about uh this is ter or tell the
treasurer about the the composition of
the assets that we managed to have uh to
me uh to be talking about ethereum and
Bitcoin and and those kind of meme
stocks is uh literally a waste of time
we need we need more income that's the
only cure okay so let's I we should be
talking about again we're not we're
talking about the rain day fund we're
talking about if we're if we're suddenly
doing so
well and we're selling lots of liquor
and we're and that we have you know
suddenly have have more money than than
you would can you imagine and we want to
stash it away that if there is at that
point in time in history which is not
you know necessarily today that there is
an uh capitalization market
capitalization of an entity that is $500
billion
doll would you say that she I'm not
impressed I'm not impressed so it's uh
what we need right now is something
that's tangible and and the only you're
looking short term I get it I am looking
only term we need income
so we need to we don't need to have tax
cuts we need to have tax increases and
and I'm saying we have an interest in
dividends tax okay I think we had an
election we actually decided that we
were going to go with we're going to
regret repeal the
interest I have a question yes yes and
you'll have to forgive me you may have
already answered it but because I can't
see your lips I don't have any clue what
you're saying okay all right to yeah
just talk to the mic I'm sorry don't
talk to me talk to the
mic we' were talking about being the
investment especially for crypto being
in the revenue stabilization which is
the rainy day which we call the rainy
day fund right but it also says well the
property taxes the general fund that's
part I'm having a problem
with okay so you would want to Del lead
from general fund or any other fund if
St Revenue state for now the revenue
stabilization fund is where that kind of
investment or any other funds that is
authorized by the legislature if we have
something authorized right right now for
this purposes of this bill it's the
rainy day fund if we delete we delete
yeah so over the previous year from the
general fund right so you want to delete
from the general fund from the re
Revenue stabilization fund or any other
funds that is authorized by the
legislature which would be yes future
okay are you okay with that delete ke
I'd like to run it by the treasurer if
that's
okay I'd like to run it by the treasurer
to see if she will give an opinion about
striking that okay and uh one of the
things in the conversation uh we talked
about pensions and long-term funds you
know they they need to be thinking about
20 years into the future right pensions
make sense sort of so I don't know if
the
language if we strike that if that would
undermine that the problem of having
working funds general fund no but I
would think it it had to be some
something we would then have
to authorize by the legislature because
right now we're just doing it says from
general fund and the re R and the
revenue stabilization
fund so if we were going to do other
funds in the future we would have to
authorize it that would have to come
back as a separate bill yes represent
Keith when and there's good reason for
that also because they are changing
things at the federal level we don't
know exactly where that's going makes
perfect sense to me okay repr thank you
Keith when you talk to the treasurer
would you find out whether in fact they
do allow equities in the Pension funds
because it yeah certainly would you like
maybe we can schedule appointment
together and because you have much more
financial expertise than I do so I I I
think your bill here is sort of jumping
over the logical next thing which is is
equities right right ter okay
so you guys will you guys will set up a
meeting
and Chris okay I think that would be
perfect with the two of you I I don't
think it should just be the two of them
well you can come too I want to be there
too yes
okay okay then
represent does anybody else would like
one okay you would be talking to the
wrong person that is true okay all right
so the three of you will be a
subcommittee of the subcommittee uh who
will uh have that conversation and other
than that is there anything else that
anybody in here has any questions or
concerns
by speak now forevermore hold your
piece okay it's going to scheduled it uh
Keith will I will do it Keith will take
Zoom
okay all right can I be added if he's
doing on Zoom yes okay so you Keith will
you put me on on the zoom representative
post sure that's Goodbody two Dems two
Republicans Perfect all right we capping
it at that yeah we're capping at that
okay can I can I make one uh
suggestion okay uh when we do the
commissions two of this and two of that
I would like to see a
professional uh investor somebody uh
that's going to do pro and con for us
because I've had a a I have heard
nothing about the stablecoin and Bitcoin
that's uh con except for me and and I I
know I know there's a big uh uh a very
good argument on my side but I I don't
think anybody here actually has ever has
ever been exposed to it and I would like
to see a professional uh person on like
a Michael Hudson or somebody like that
who absolutely knows but this is
committee this is in our committee this
is not a commission this is a committee
it would be a lot cheaper to bring
somebody in like that and we get the
full dope okay may I just interu one
thing you can invite them to the next
subcommittee yes Keith so narrowing the
scope of of what I think we're going to
talk to the treasur about we're going to
talk about removing general fund right
leaving it in or removing it and we're
going to talk about why isn't the list a
little more expansive and and and those
two those the pension fund and then and
then and why aren't we
including uh
stocks why aren't we including stocks
is in the PCH right limited to well it
has mutual funds but it's limited to a
fixed income mutual funds why why aren't
we Mr Ken why aren't we including
stocks okay I think those are great
okay all right so the 310 is just a
study
okay
um all right so is there anybody in the
audience who represents an organization
commission how expert do you have to be
how expert do you have to be you don't
have to have any expertise
right I mean we we have well I I do see
that there has three members of the
House of Representative appointed by the
speaker so if you would like to increase
the chance that you get
appointed we uh it would not be unusual
for us to say um certain amount of those
members would be from the Commerce
Committee I I would have no problem
doing it with the understanding that I'm
not a stock broker or any of those kind
of things but I can do research better
than it and gang
busters
right yes represent BR my concern is and
how could we alleviate that Reg great if
they're members of the Commerce
Committee that I mean we've had some
commissions that were I don't for lack
of a better word stacked in One
Direction or another so how can we Ure I
like the idea of having an independent
expert um uh can we can we make how can
we make thaten got figure out who that
how how you want to describe that person
and make sure they get appointed so like
I say that um if if we wrote uh you it
says three members of the House of
Representatives and two of which is from
the Commerce Committee I can guarantee
you that I would uh appoint oh you get
to appoint them the speaker would come
to me he would I'm sorry say that the
two least
two
from the Commerce Committee I'd like to
make a comment if I could
yep the results of the Dow commission
that uh happened last year or the final
thing came out last year was actually
quite good I mean the the the results of
that d commiss were good the bill that
we passed out of the house was quite
good the bill that came out of the
Senate after it got edited took a few
things out that I did not particularly
like but that's going to happen with any
bill and it's not the fault of the
commission because the commission
actually as I said they did a good job
uh I'm hoping that we have the same kind
of quality at least the same kind of
quality as we had on the Dow Commission
because if we can get that something
that good and by the way I did look at a
bunch of the states
and there's eight states that are
setting up these commissions have
already started setting them up so it's
this okay
great um and uh did you notice in terms
of who they had on their commission that
that we don't have on ours or anybody
that you think should be add I looked at
I can give you that list because I don't
remember and I didn't bother to write it
down but I have the list at home okay
and I can bring it in and but it's kind
of similar the way we have it although
one state did say they were going to
hire professionals to be on the
commission but we don't have a fiscal
note with this no no so I don't know how
we would hire anybody right if they if
they need to hire somebody they'll have
to come back and and get so actually
that that leads to to my point is um the
sunset is uh 2025 November 20 and I I
would say we should push that out of a
year because it's going to take a long
time to get the appointments made and I
don't want I think that we should give
them the full buy any name I had this
similar feeling that three months is a
it's a big bite to chew in three months
okay so let's go
2026 we we may want to uh and then and
then the
repeal is
2026 so L 23 on page first page of the
bill we may want to bump it up to
two blockchains yeah two people that are
familiar with the technology right okay
I think we could find those based on
what it was on the governor's commission
okay good what's the technology you just
cited is this the Bitcoin business no
this is uh it would be for stable a
stable token and that's recorded on the
blockchain so the technology is
blockchain but there's also financial
pieces to it you know traditional
financial pieces to
it again I uh I that that doesn't
qualify in my mind uh what kind of uh
information we need to have at the
professional
level uh well um your your homework
assignment is to figure out who you
think is the right person and we'll put
them on I have a bunch of names but uh
don't ask don't ask you go ask those
names ask those
people what is their nature of their
expertise so that we can get them
appointed we don't you I've never seen a
commission where we actually put
somebody's name down on the commission
we would have what is their title what
is their Prof and and we'll we'll add
them
to on the list well I could make a list
but I'm not going to go around and call
uh and do that work I'm just not going
to and by the way they're going to cost
money
well then then they really don't care
about this problem then if they're if
they're going to cost money they're
going to just shake us down to be on a
committee to to help us set the
framework then then no they're experts
in in what we talk about well if they're
an expert that they would want to be on
this
commission I don't everyone I know is
not from New Hampshire so oh so nobody
you w have anybody from New
Hampshire not yet I mean I would have to
go to some go to your friends and ask
him who's somebody from New Hampshire
who could be
pointed I wouldn't trust it I don't like
the politics here no really this is a
this is an area that most help me out
you want you want something and I'm
giving you the opportunity to do it you
you got to you got to have a little
effort here you got to you
know effort effort here you unless you
want me to go find someone but I how how
I'm sure is that whoever I find probably
you won't like so you you need to find
somebody help help if you want Keith to
help you maybe I guess but you've got
you got to find somebody who is willing
this all right I mean I I can give you
names of uh economists that I read okay
and and who would probably give uh some
great
information uh they don't know me I you
know no I'm not asking that they know
you but you you respect their opinion do
so send send to me and Keith their their
email addresses and we'll contact them
all
right
okay anybody
else Academia it does have I did see uh
I said yeah yeah 27 one represented for
the academic Community with expertise in
financial regulation that's un or block
technology yeah we have that UNH
commission there were two it says
or uh one represented from an economic
Community with an expertise in financial
technology
okay will you sending out an amendment
or something that says what we all
agreed to here so the next step is is
taking what we've discussed here and we
would have the Amendments drawn
up but that I I I I can't emphasize
enough that I'm open to um anything in
terms of what the commission shall study
and make
recommendations read that list if you
see something that you would like them
to be focused on you need to get that to
me and
Keith okay so any any of the tasks or
the Warm Bodies if you anybody has a
brilliant idea police get it to Keith
and then we will have it and then by the
time you know once I've coated that
we'll have the amendment drawn up and
then I'll call another subcomm do you
want me to put together everything that
the other states are doing in their
commissions I what I mostly particularly
interested is hearing what you think out
of after your analysis of that
which items in there do you think we
need to add can I have until tomorrow or
you have a week two weeks can I just
sure interject one we're not we're this
this is not an early bill so and I'm
only going to and I'm only going to uh
include those that have actually passed
legislation that's fine that's great so
I we we don't want to we don't want to
micromanage the duties of the commission
too much but one of the tasks could be
to investigate what the other states are
doing and include that in we could that
that keep it keep it simple and but I
don't I don't mind putting together a
list just so that we have it I mean
that'll come in super handy
yeah okay so what what is this bill
310 okay this is not a early bill so we
have all the time in the world sort
of okay everybody feel comfortable with
least oh excuse me last and least yes
sorry okay prohibiting the denial of
banking Insurance Services based on any
factor that is quanti partial and risk
base as measured by an objective
standard okay do we have anybody here
359 who who was the sponsor this
bill
cork that a is it is he he is this the
one that he didn't show up for the
hearing another no show
yeah oh my God no no car sponsors
either this one yeah that what you're
okay all right so as some of you were
here this morning you I'm not too
anxious to kill things I want to make
sure that if they watch the tape they
know that
we did did due diligence we didn't just
kill it because nobody showed up so
let's tell us why you don't like this
bill I will sure the Department of
Justice
the bankers Association the domestic
insurance representativ State Farm
Insurance All State Insurance social
responsibility organization and
sustainability group all opposed the
bill and said that it was
essentially uh against free trade and a
bunch of other things that they said and
when the dog already doj says that they
don't like it the bankers don't like
it I don't know I nobody lik it and I
don't like it I I don't think this
I don't think this belongs in the Live
State okay you move IPL I I'm I'm do I
feel like you're okay so our first
rationale is we is that no one actually
came in and spoke for the bill right
which is not a good thing was all
negatives
anybody speak for the bill right I
already posed that question no notice
department
yes so I I also don't think this bill is
ready for prime time um there there is a
legitimate issue behind this bill I
think um there was a and I think I
shared this with with uh some of you
that uh uh Mark andreon who's a big
investor was recently on The Joe Rogan
podcast this is maybe a month ago and he
talked about how all these Tech
investors were being
debanked and once he came came out and
publicly stated that a lot of the other
you know Founders and innovators were
saying that they were also be being
debanked that they they uh some of them
had to like not even pursue their their
uh you know building a company because
they couldn't find a bank that would
Bank them so I I think there is an issue
but I don't know if the government can
solve it at the state level I think it's
going to be a federal they have to clean
this up at the federal level and and I
think that's going to happen um he'll
try right um so I want to just give some
Credence
to the intentions behind the bill I
think there are some sound intentions
but this particular bill I don't see us
uh us wanting to pass it yeah no I I
agree that every every bill has a grain
of truth to it and uh and and a
rationale for why um you know what why
something go through and and a lot of
you in terms of you say debanked or
accusations that certain things are
going on um
but in terms of um you know in our case
we we have state chartered Banks and I'm
sure that the de banking is not
occurring so much in our state Charter
Banks it was going to be it's going to
be a bigger bank and I'm pretty sure
those bigger Banks um are not active in
New Hampshire anyways it's federally
chared Banks um in terms of the
insurance portion of the
bill it it seemed like they they got
dragged into something that really
wasn't you know not not their fault um
you know I think I I because I saw this
more is more of a financial it's a
banking bill than than an insurance bill
and and it seemed un unfortunate that
insurance got thrown into it
also but um we know insurance has a
problem when it comes to nonprofits
so
motion represent Cole
meler any discussion on the
motion okay all those of the business
committee who favor of the motion please
say
I can keep your hands
committee
okay and with
sure